in a galaxy far away gravity didn't
quite work the way it does on earth and
the speed at which everything moves is
ruined weird too maybe some places in
our vast universe just don't abide by
our laws of physics and if that was true
what would it mean for us this is what
if and here's what would happen if the
universe isn't uniform
if you stargaze long enough and I mean
really long you might notice that the
galaxies are getting further apart
here's the deal with our universe for
all we know it started as a single point
and it's been expanding ever since the
Big Bang
although gravity is supposed to crash
things back together the galaxies keep
moving away from each other
driven by a mysterious hypothetical
force we call dark energy and it's
speeding up a few studies have shown
that some places in the universe aren't
expanding the way we expect them to
making our understanding of the
principal laws of physics wrong
so what if everything we know about the
universe is wrong if every corner of the
universe turned out to be different it
would crash the cosmological principle
that explains how the universe works we
see the universe as isotropic or a
uniform we expect that stars planets and
galaxies in the farthest corner of the
universe behave exactly like they do
here in the Milky Way galaxy a
non-uniform universe would be
anisotropic and all that would mean is
that the fundamental laws of physics are
universal after all some distant places
in the universe could have totally
different cosmological constants like
the speed of light in our corner of the
universe light travels at 300,000
kilometers per second and nothing can
travel faster than light but in an
anisotropic universe the speed of light
could be different in some places it
might be faster allowing some alien
civilizations to travel very quickly
across their galactic neighborhood but
in other places the speed of light might
be slower making everything in that part
of the universe move work more slower
gravity could work differently across
the universe - there could be planets
out there where gravity would be
strongest on the objects with smaller
masses
and maybe just maybe those planets would
have stars orbiting them and not the
other way around
maybe some places in the universe would
have gravity that changes depending on
the time of day and maybe the alien
species inhabiting such wolves would
have bodies that adapt to those changing
gravitational conditions but none of
this would change how things work here
on earth so what's in it for us we
determine the distance between objects
in the universe based on these
principles as we know them if the
universe isn't uniform we could be wrong
about how far the Andromeda galaxy is
from us and how soon it will collide
with our galaxy the Milky Way
we could have miscalculated how long it
would take to go to Proxima Centauri we
could be wrong about the age of the
universe - if the universe isn't the
same everywhere then it might make space
exploration easier for us we just need
to understand all the different
principles of the universe and use them
to our advantage
but that could also make interstellar
travel more difficult leaving us limited
to only exploring and colonizing our own
solar system but hey that could be fun
too as long as you know how to survive
on the planets we've yet to colonize and
we have a show for you about just that
to help you survive whatever awaits you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you